Hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel. Uh this week's video is
hopefully going to be a little bit
shorter uh because I had a bit of a
COVID scare this week. That's right.
They're coming to get your boy. They
being a virus. Uh but it didn't happen.
So I'm going to do this video going to
save the deep dives for next week. And
uh yeah, let's go ahead and get into it.
In this video, we're going to be
building out a really simplistic version
of the Facebook or Twitter newsfeed.
This means no fancy machine learning, no
security permissions, and unfortunately,
no thirst traps. Simply put, our
newsfeed for this problem is a
chronological list of posts from users
that you follow. This implies that we'll
have to build out a few different
functions. So, let's list them. Being
able to create a post, being able to
follow another user, and finally, being
able to access the post from your
newsfeed pageionated based on creation
timestamp. There are a lot of directions
that this problem can go in. For this
video, I'm going to keep things as
simple as possible and just create a
solution that I know would work. In the
next one, I'll do the deep dives, which
should focus a bit more on optimizing
this. Twitter processes around 500
million tweets per day, limited at 280
characters each. This means that there
are around 5800 tweets per second. If we
assume the content of the tweet is 280
bytes, perhaps we can also assume that
the entire size of the tweet data model
is around a kilobyte, mainly due to
metadata. This means we need to be able
to persist around 5.8 megabytes per
second of data, which is more than
doable. We'll also need to have an
estimate for the amount of people that
Twitter users follow and are followed
by. For this problem, let's estimate
that the average user has 100 followers,
but also follows 100 people. One notable
exception to this is my Gooning Burner
account, which follows many thousands.
But I digress. Keep in mind that there
are others, such as our tyrant Elon
Musk, who can have hundreds of millions
of followers. This is a perfect example
of the celebrity issue, which we'll
discuss how to handle. Imagine I'm a
user who follows 100 people. When I read
my newsfeed, I need to fetch the posts
from all 100 of those people. Recall
that we're persisting 5.8 megabytes per
second of data, meaning that each year
we post an additional 200 terabytes of
tweets. If I have a database persisting
all of these posts, one thing that I
could do to load the newsfeed is to run
a query on it trying to fetch all the
posts that I'm interested in. For users
that follow many people, this is going
to be problematic. Scanning such a huge
table for posts that you're interested
in isn't necessarily expensive in
isolation, but doing it hundreds or
thousands of times can lead to a lot of
scattering and gathering data and slower
results. This is rough considering we
want to optimize our read path. Let's
instead aim to provide users with a view
such that when they fetch their newsfeed
data, we already have a premputed list
of posts from the users that they
follow. As a quick aside before we move
on, with modern hardware, it actually
may be possible to quickly fetch all the
posts a user is interested in on the
fly. If we establish reasonable limits
on how many users a person can follow,
this could be doable. Nevertheless,
we'll save that for the deep dives
video. Similarly to our last video, we
want users to be able to read their own
rights after they create a post. I'll
take the same approach here as last time
and have the application server sync
data into a post database. Given that
we'll eventually be fetching posts based
on the user ID of the author, it also
seems advantageous to partition our post
database based on the author's ID.
Within each author's post, we can sort
them by their creation timestamp.
Fortunately, each individual user
doesn't make too many posts, so this
table shouldn't have many hotspots from
right traffic. I'm going to assume there
is zero privacy measures and that you
can follow any user you please. When you
do, the action of following or
unfollowing a user can be sent into a
user following table. Again, this allows
users to instantly see their own rights
after they make them. Now, we're going
to introduce a second database table
called the feed table. This one is also
going to be partitioned on user ID and
ordered by postcreation timestamp. But
in this case, the user ID corresponds to
the user whose news feed this is.
Ordering a table in such a way allows us
to quickly get pageionated reads from a
given user's feed based on the time
stamp. As we scroll on a client device,
we can keep supplying the timestamp of
the last scene post in order to get
older results. To make this a seamless
experience on the front-end device, we
can make the next call to the feed table
after we've scrolled halfway through the
currently displayed posts. When we
publish a tweet, it goes into our post
table. We can then employ change data
capture from there into Kafka. Doing so
allows us to register a Kafka consumer
to take in the post and figure out all
the users that should see it in their
feed. From there, a set of consumers can
fan out the data to all interested
parties by sending it to many rows of
the feed table corresponding to each
follower of the tweet. I personally do a
lot of fanning out myself after I fart
in a crowded room. We'll only consider a
fan out successful once all of the
newsfeed rows are successfully written.
Since these table updates are item
potent, we can retry them to our heart's
content. We can run a background job to
expire old tweets from this table. Note
that in the Kafka consumer I mentioned
that we need to figure out all followers
of a given tweet. However, right now we
just have a table that maps a user to
all the people that they follow.
However, right now we just have a table
that maps a user to all the people that
they follow. We need a quick mapping
from a user to all the people that
followed them. This is simple enough to
achieve with a global secondary index.
This would likely require a distributed
transaction to achieve it, significantly
slowing down write latencies in favor of
strong consistency between the two
tables. One exception that I'm aware of
is Dynamo DB, which actually supports
asynchronous global secondary indexes.
However, in our case, we can build it
ourselves with change data capture. We
can use DZM to pipe changes from one
table to another via Kafka and a
stateless consumer. Dynamo DB is likely
doing something similar under the hood,
but now we're not tied to a specific
cloud provider. In theory, fetching a
user's newsfeed is as simple as one
database read. In practice, the fanning
out of tweets to create one database
write per follower doesn't work so well.
For example, let's imagine that Elon
tweets for the thousandth time that he's
owned the liberals. If this gets sent
through our normal CDC flow, we'll have
to fan it out to 185 million database
rights. That just isn't feasible.
Instead, for users like Elon, our Kafka
consumer should just drop the message.
When users fetch their newsfeed, they
can go to the post DB to get tweets from
popular users. We can quickly figure out
who a user is following from our user
following table, load popular tweets
from the post DB, fetch unpopular tweets
from the newsfeed table, and then merge
those together. This implies that we
also need a quick way of determining
whether a tweet author is a popular user
so we know whether to query the post DB
for their tweets. In our design, every
single one of Elon's followers would
fetch his tweets from the post DB. This
table could quickly get overloaded. To
avoid this, let's add an LRU caching
layer in front of our database. Using
something like Reddus could work, which
could be scaled and partitioned based on
the hash of the user ID. If you watched
the last video about Facebook likes,
you'll recall that counting large
amounts of rows isn't trivial. When
checking if a user is popular, we may
have to do a pretty large scan of a
database to get their follower count.
When fetching news feeds, we need to
quickly determine whether a user is
popular, so we know whether to load
their tweets from the post DB. Let's
imagine that we'll only go to the post
DB with users with over 10,000
followers. If we estimate that this
is.1% of Twitter's user base, this caps
us at 1 million users. The amount of
storage that it takes for us to store a
million user IDs is 1 million * 8 bytes,
which is 8 megabytes. We can keep this
all in a reddis cache and replicate it
to our heart's content in order to serve
many read requests. We can update these
Reddis caches every day or so by running
a Spark job to recomputee which users
are popular. Application servers and fan
out Kafka consumers can even cache this
information themselves with a fairly
short TTL. Let's go through our final
design by implementing our three main
APIs. Creating a tweet, following a
user, and fetching a newsfeed. First,
let's create a post. Then let's follow a
user. For our newsfeed APIs, we need to
support a bunch of types of fast reads.
The first requires maintaining an index
to figure out a user's followers. Next,
we need to be able to quickly determine
which users are popular. This comes in
handy to avoid fanning out popular
tweets and figuring out which tweets we
should load from the post DB. Now, we
can listen to change data capture from
our post database in order to fan out
posts to a tweet author's followers.
We'll only do so for posts from
unpopular authors. When fetching a feed,
we'll first begin by reading from the
feed database. In parallel, we'll figure
out which popular authors this user
follows by comparing who they follow
with the set of popular authors. We'll
fetch posts from this list of popular
users. Now, taking advantage of our post
look aside cache where possible. We're
using change data capture a lot in this
problem. Let's review its benefits. If
we want two views to stay in sync with
one another, we have a few options. The
first is to update one and then update
the other. This has the advantage of
being fairly fast, but can lead to data
inconsistencies if one of the rights
succeeds and the other fails. The second
is to use a distributed transaction.
Internally, these rely on the two-phase
commit protocol. In a two-phase commit,
a transaction coordinator reaches out to
both syncs to confirm that they're
prepared to accept the right and then
commits the right after receiving both
responses. Having so many network round
trips makes this a fairly slow process.
We should probably avoid it unless we
need perfect data integrity. A middle
ground is change data capture. This
allows us to send our right to one view
and then use a system like DZium to
transport the data to Kafka. We can use
downstream consumers to sync the data to
other systems. Since data in Kafka is
durable, the two views should eventually
be in sync assuming the source database
doesn't lose the right. This keeps our
right latencies to the post DB and
followers table fairly fast while
allowing us to still build global
secondary indices on those tables. In
this problem, we use Apache Cassandra a
lot. Cassandra is a leaderless database.
It relies on quorum consistency in order
to ensure that we will see data that
we've previously written. Compared to
single leader databases, Cassandra
prioritizes availability. While single
leader databases can perform failover
when the leader goes down, this process
often takes a few seconds. This is due
to the other database nodes trying to
come to an agreement on whether the
leader is actually dead. Cassandra lacks
any single leader for writing to, thus
avoiding a failover process. For social
media like Twitter or Facebook, getting
perfect data consistency is a bit less
important to us than write availability
is. It would really stink, for example,
if I'm sitting here getting errors for
10 seconds while I'm trying to fire off
a banger tweet. Even for our newsfeed
table, having high right availability is
important. If a newsfeed shard were
unable to accept writes for a few
seconds, we'd delay processing any of
the tweets being sent to those feeds.
Thanks everyone for coming. Uh hopefully
this one wasn't too overwhelming. I
understand I'm still not highlighting
things with my cursor on the screen, but
I'm trying to be a little bit better
about making incremental diagrams. So,
please do let me know if that works or
uh you hate me and uh you want to go
stab me or something like that. Please
don't, but you know, whatever. Uh deep
dive video will be next week. I'm
looking forward to doing it. Let's speak
in the next one.